Monica Rogati who has
moved around a little bit,
but she's an important data
science leader and writer,
has the data science
hierarchy of needs
or the AI hierarchy of needs.
At the bottom are things like
logging and collecting data.
And then you move up and things
at the middle are analytics.
And things like
machine learning are
way at the top of this pyramid.
And in terms of value
that people get,
you get a lot of
value from analytics,
from counting things.
You get a lot of value
from your first models
you train, like simple
models, linear models.
It's like you have
to be pretty mature.
You have to be pretty up
to your hierarchy of needs
to be able to the point
where you're like,
I need fancy machine
learning model
that's learning
non-linear relationships
or taking advantage
of complicated math.
I wouldn't say I'm motivated
to work on machine learning
because it's the thing
that offers the most value
or that it's the thing that
solves the most problems.
Because I think the
thing that solves
the most problems is making
data accessible to people
in their workplaces,
and that they
have the tools to be able
to do basic analytics
or train that first model.
You get the biggest wins
at those lower levels.
I do think the problem is, like,
machine learning tooling is
interesting because
it is complex
and people enter into it with
different levels of experience.
And being able to
build tools to make
that process more streamlined
is an interesting challenge.